hi guys so this past weekend was VidCon
of course you probably know that already
because I've been tweeting and making
videos non-staff about this event I had
such an awesome time and I met so many
amazing people in this video is pretty
much just going to be one big shout out
and bunch of clips of things that happen
this past weekend make sure you guys
take a few minutes after this video to
check out all the people that I
mentioned in this video because they are
awesome subscribe watch their videos and
show them some YouTube love I did it
awesome ask IJ IRL that stands for in
real life
normally when people do a presentation
you're supposed to say on stage but I
didn't do a very good job of that hi how
are you huge shout-out to Jumoke TV
because he pretty much saved the day we
all wanted to do a little dance party up
on stage we didn't have any music so he
came up and saying an amazing song Oh
another person who I met who is now my
favorite youtuber of all time is Josh
Sundquist but I just thought about him a
few days before VidCon I watched all of
his videos and let me just say thumbs up
if you guys think that we should do a
wrap together real true answer was my
leg to cancer but it don't stop the
other one like a dancer I can prank
let's see walk and Soulja Boy too I can
do the stanky leg gee how about you I
also was giving out a ton of t-shirts
throughout the event and here's someone
who really enjoyed the t-shirt well
these people is easy don't why is that
amazing t shirt you're wearing I'm
wearing this pic hey you can ask
what do you best guy Jay today what's
your favorite treat mizo let me
highlight were the guys from route Barry
they were like hey Justine we would love
for you to participate in our on stage
presentation but here's the catch we
want to juggle machetes around you
naturally after a few minutes of thought
I said okay cools and all fun and games
got into a few arguments with miss olga
kay so ogen i have a little disagreement
biggest Shane is Marion and she keeps
trying to get all up in my territory hey
Shane Dawson easier yes
I did I get to meet spirit 24 but I got
to meet her beautiful little baby Lulu
and let me tell you she is going to be
the next video blogger for sure
awesome time hang out with Patrick [ __ ]
kitty nanalew Mitchell Davis and Kyle we
also played a little prank on Mitchell's
called the no soap radio joke if you
want to check that video out it's on my
other channel shout out to Roberto from
throw boy calm at the end of my ass hi
Jay show he threw out a ton of subscribe
close to everyone and I also noticed
something I am not very good at throwing
anything one of the most amazing things
to witness is when Shane Dawson walks
into a room
it was like if Justin Bieber walked into
a middle school it was a little
something along those lines I've been
watching external time X for a while on
youtube and i actually got to meet him
you are the most professional video blog
and the huge shout-out goes to club gaga
on YouTube he made me a lady gaga disco
stick and it's pretty much the coolest
thing ever you should channel and what
you do um my name is Eddie on my channel
is called gaara and I make lady gaga
from Sasha Li ke made me an amazing
apple logo candle and it smells
delicious there was also a dailybooth
photo booth Rachel tons of pictures a
lot of my friends hey who's that oh yeah
that's Jane bow and when I you said a
lot of pictures I met like a lot a lot
of pictures I had such an awesome time
at VidCon I can't think the vlogbrothers
enough John and Hank for doing such an
amazing job at keeping this event
together it was unbelievable and I can't
wait until next year there better be a
next year because it's amazing and i
can't wait just all of you guys there
okay um bye